dr catalin curico is a hungarian-born
biochemist whose research is responsible
for the mrna vaccines that are in many
of our arms protecting us against copen
dr curico got her phd in hungary and she
immigrated to the united states in 1985
with her husband
and her young daughter there were rules
about how much money you could come over
with at the time
so she stuffed the equivalent of about
in her daughter's teddy bear uh before
coming here so
came here with very little got a job at
the university of pennsylvania
in about 1990 she was working on
this research about something called
mrna a traditional vaccine
takes a dead virus or piece of that
virus
and introduces it to your body in order
to train your immune system to fight it
but an mrna vaccine does something
unique
rather than giving you a piece of the
virus it
instead gives you a program or message
to your body and your cells themselves
make a piece of that virus and that
piece of virus trains your immune system
to fight the whole virus what makes this
more impressive is that because
all you need is the genetic code of a
virus you can actually produce vaccines
much more quickly than you can using
traditional methods
it's cutting-edge science it's never
been used in
a widespread vaccine like this before
and dr curico
saw the potential in mrna science back
in 1990
she studied it at penn for years five
years in fact
until in 1995 she got devoted
in effect she was ahead of her time
almost too far ahead
because she kept applying for grants and
the answer kept coming back
no she had no money she had no backing
uh so she was demoted
and sent back to a lower level of the
scientific academy
she wasn't fired so it allowed her to
keep doing the work
but it was a huge step back in
the trajectory of her career so her
husband was back in hungary at this
point dealing with the visa issue
and she was diagnosed with cancer no one
would fault her for giving up by
it would be enough to topple anyone
between the demotion
and getting ill yourself she knew there
was potential but her bosses did not
but there was always one person who
believed in her and she has actually
said that
really all it takes is one if you have
one person who buys into your idea and
can fund you and give you enough money
to live on
you your career can survive and that's
effectively what happened to her
drew weissman is her longtime
collaborator at penn
she really tried to get funding all
through the 90s and she
said every night i was working grant
grant grant
and it always came back no no
no she has heard no so many times
and the fact that she persisted until
she was successful
until we now all or those of us who've
gotten vaccinated have this science
in our bloodstream that is why she is on
the 50 over 50.
a lot of the stories on this list are
stories of triumph
our stories of persistence continuing to
work
even when the world is telling you stop
and
she didn't just do it for her she did it
for humankind
it was difficult because the people did
not believe
that messenger rna can be a therapy
and together with my colleague drew
weisman
at the university of pennsylvania we
developed
this method where we changed one
component in the rna
which made it less immunogenic and
it is possible to use it for different
kind of therapy
and also it turns out that it is
is better for vaccine these vaccines
are able to be scaled up quickly they
have proven to be
highly effective even against viral
mutations
and they are incredibly safe even by the
standards of vaccines
which are themselves very safe compared
to other drugs
by refining the research by refining the
science
they figured out a way to make it safe
and that is why the technology
was finally at a point that it was so
promising when
covid became a pandemic and it became
clear that
mrna science would
underpin the most successful vaccine
patents that she shares with dr drew
wiseman
are licensed to both biointec and
moderna
for their mrna vaccines her discoveries
which help these vaccines deliver their
potent immune boosts
were originally developed for cancer
vaccines
and continued to be applied to research
in that area
mrna technology behind the vaccines is
also being filled
against other diseases such as the flu
and even heart disease and really we
will celebrate when uh
you know this uh human suffering is over
when you know the hardship and all of
this
terrible time will end and hopefully in
the summer
when we will forget about virus and
vaccine then
then then i will be really celebrating
every story about these vaccines there's
a reference to her
uh one of the heroes you know the unsung
hero
you you see the term again again and
again she is finally getting credit
you